we're learning about possible timeline
in the case of gabby potito who vanished
during a cross-country trip with her
fiance a body matching potato's
description was found in wyoming over
the weekend authorities are still
looking for her fiance brian laundry who
returned the loan to his home in florida
on september first tarika duncan reports
on the search for answers in this
disturbing case
more than a dozen fbi agents raided the
laundry home on monday they confiscated
boxes of evidence including computers
and towed away laundry silver mustang
parked in the driveway a second search
warrant details the timeline of petito's
disappearance in one notable section it
describes an odd text message on august
27 from petito's phone to her mother
asking to help stan her mother became
concerned because she never referred to
stan her grandfather by his first name
from that point on her phone was no
longer operational and she stopped
posting on social media something her
family said was not normal behavior i'd
like to report a domestic dispute a
florida license plate white land
about two weeks earlier there was this
made 911 august 12. we drove by and the
gentleman was slapping the girl he was
slapping her
yes and then we stopped they ran up and
down the sidewalk he proceeded to hit
her hopped in the car
and they drove off police body cam video
shows the immediate aftermath of that
call we just been fighting all morning
and
he wouldn't let me in the car before why
wouldn't he let you in the car
neither party wanted to file charges and
police did not the couple the next day
continued their trip to wyoming where
the remains believed to belong to gabby
potito were eventually found
[Applause]
and preliminary autopsy results are
expected today to confirm if those
remains are in fact that of gabby
potatoes meanwhile that
search for brine laundry at a nearby
nature reserve has been called off as
investigators say they have exhausted
all avenues when it comes to the search
for him there
we will continue to cover this story
with 48 hours and have much more on this
story in the coming days tony
all right tarika thank you very much